perché facevamo ha fatto la maco beni
già lancio senza di me
buongiorno la pizza fino vissuto tutto
dopo colazione difficilmente più
richiesti in assoluto una challenge già
famosissima negli stati uniti infatti è
stata lanciata da youtube america e
della pausa challenge è però con tribal
perché noi abbiamo già fatto da un
fantasma legge se non lo avete visto
deve lasciare in questo video fatti e
vita anni ha fatto uno scherzetto
terribile quindi andate a vederla poi ci
vedremo per le coste chavez piano con di
slime ha creato un telecomando
ce l'ho io
no
ecco stesura possiamo andare lontano
abbiamo cercato ha detto metallo
possiamo mettere in fatto da un'altra
persona e quando la mettiamo quindi
sedimenti pausa si dà da mangiare a mano
che poi con lo slang quindi allora del
video mi metterò qua il sondaggio e
potrete votare subito io sì ha vinto
l'italia in falsetto il prezzo sul
insieme a dell'utri a como donna votate
subito perché dovete prima vedere il
video viral api e è vedere come l'ottavo
quindi non gravi la nottata siamo al tar
d'italia la profilassi un bel letto se
volete vedere altre sale rischio
pensando di farne un'altra in cui questo
nella pausa facciamo mai si sveglia cioè
che riavvolgiamo quindi torna indietro
fatto dell'ingrediente lasciate un bel
line che se volete vedere anche la
rewind business male stiamo bene
inventati se questo video rigidissimi
adesso andremo farla bene
andiamo con due cose diverse io la con
la trasparente e vitale a quella bianca
e trasparenti mischiata con disegnata
dai grossi becchiamo hai fatto partire
un vantaggio perché tanto già stare che
farò un disastro
questo perché io voglio fare una slide
mosti renato normale speriamo di
riuscirci
la cosa bella di questa legge che
fossimo film che scegliere noi tutti gli
ingredienti non c'è più la ruota o
possiamo inserire quello che mettiamo le
cose poi far finalmente gare e poi
uscirà pure bossi perché trasparente e
quindi possiamo già prendere tutto
quello che vogliamo
quella che allora io mi metto il
colorante
non so se farlo rosa salette il tacco di
jankovic ser e così s un bel news live
sirenetta
ecco un video questo già letto comitato
non vuoi perdere
no no ma voglio fino al vento ma pro la
maledizione del verde perché non sarà
più il caso al cospetto di reggio si
prende così tanti big man
ecco che devo fare i taxi che è composto
da tanti big man da mettere in istituti
di colori e che un bel libro marrone
ma chi ha detto no
che bello sempre giarola pca3 aggiungere
[Musica]
allora secondo me potresti aggiungere il
bird per esempio per cominciare a
trovare un meccanismo portobello papa va
bene ho messo poco soprattutto per
davvero non volevo farlo apposta aver
ottenuto sviluppo da e dai non è male
dove di tanzi de aiutato a farlo color
sirena guarda che bello c'è già queste
sfumature stupende qui
ma dove il proprio verde palude a 5
vediamo che cosa possa fare mi metto già
qui a girare questo viola che ho omesso
si vede solo brano pausa per non farmi
male io sono tuttora non si diverte
scusa perché si sa che sono un po perché
in realtà chi conoscendo proprio al meno
te lo aspetti
me la pagherà i fatti ma pure fari su
slam che continua con cena ci sarà e
cosa si aspettano lo aspetta come faccio
a migliorarlo qua adesso che colorano
lettere per di più ma chi lo sta infatti
normale che sia così dura tra sassari e
con le facce con ora bellissimo
guardatelo io prendo un pigmento vediamo
sei diventato modesta un complimento
celeste tutti i pigmenti nostro
proposito non vado neanche io tantissimo
wow
vediamo un po affrettato bellissimo per
lato
[Musica]
allora vediamo cita stroke e fattagli da
serena e so già tutto il perimetro sulle
mani ha sporcato il tavolo o al solito o
facendo qui il mio galaxy cominciando a
prendere forma comincia a girarlo un
pochettino vediamo contento allora
dunque dicevamo andiamo avanti con la
pausa challenge me trani perché bloccata
spitale sta facendo il suo bello slide
galaxy
allora dopo aver messo a big mento io
adesso aggiungerei i glitter aggiunge
minikit rista di un'italia che questa
pausa challenger impossessato dal canale
di mettere i nostri bei l'inter
io poi sono bravo norton neanche
rovinando troppo il tuo slime forse ce
li metto nel tuo per nove mesto nel mio
questo bambino però potrei aggiungersi
magari del pigmento verde nel suo che
aggiungo che dite che già un gattino o
dari sono un bravo per ogni scelgo tutti
i pigmenti del mio slime per fare il
galaxy finalmente si possa fare pensate
sorbelli poi aggiungete le idee
dell'interno come il blick metteranno
questo e chiudono nome tanto l'inter
neri poco poco nero ti piace questo qui
questo e prendendo possesso del canale
la città vive un pausa dai video solo in
italia
più attento si divertirebbero sacco
qualcuno allora andiamo a mischiare il
mio bellissimo piccola lite un po mi
dispiace
la pausa dalle pause giusto necessari
problema alla camera per far vedere bene
se pagano si guarda in basso così impari
aspetta che ne ancora un pochino
guarda che bello così impari mi fate
arrabbiare questo per te hai testato la
mia pazienza ora perfetti rai meno
roviniamo tutto bellissimo garatti
diventerà tutto grigio mezzo
mettiamo che del verde come altro potete
fidarvi
[Musica]
un po di blu anche così esce bello
marroncino per tutto il tempo di
minestra testo ricorda cosa impari mi
velluto gli tira nome la conservo per
dopo 66 ma ora sembra bellissimo sempre
un bel mix di colori ma è da quando
prenderà il nero diventa un bel non c'è
il mero vedi definisce libero stato no
no pensavo che avesse rischio del verde
grigio grigio così infatti troppo stato
tutti cattivo poi o via notare è stata
così cattiva ma io non sono stato così
cattivo solo messo per sbaglio un po di
verde a casa per un quarto d'ora grazie
mi che non sono neanche andato a
mangiare ma quattro secondo che anzi mi
ha aiutato a fare un galaxy è riuscita
vero non ho anche agrigento agrigento si
è detto un po chiare adesso ci mettiamo
gli altri colori o ragazzi che non
riuscita un po salvarla con il pigmento
infatti diventato un po metallizzato lo
celestino quindi forse riesco ancora a
fare lo slime sirenetta marino sirena
che bello aggiungo un pochino di glitter
vediamo un pò di blu quello viola
[Musica]
chi vi partecipa non c'è molto da vivere
il tempo così ma io ho quasi finito
voglio mettere tutta per piazzare
decorazioni tipo qualcuna di queste ed
altre parole ma diventano grigi
riduzioni a rimettere per renderlo
marino il mega per da marino e l'infarto
marino palline argentate gruppo diversa
perché io il werder ma l'odio ma quando
una costante di cose che poi non si
vedranno per produrre anzi mi fa c'era
anche dice andrea purtroppo nero blu 98
altre bellissime questo lei chiuso bene
rubato ad attivarlo
fumetto quest'estetica colorato che si
permette alle marine paura posso
guadagnare un po di enfasi era rimasto
indietro col mio galaxy
allora non so quale effettivamente di
che colore sta tenendo il pianeta è
riuscito anita riuscita a rovinarmi il
colore però lo sto facendo diventare un
pochettino meno grigiume è più blu astro
qui più astro nero era un buttero come
la grazia però tutti l'interno ancora
non si vedono quindi o me devo
aggiungere di più e mi metto davanti
evento da tm 14 dic l'inter bianchi di
glitter bianchi perché non ci ho pensato
prima così almeno che ben si sono
parlati così sembrano l'estero della
casa e tutte e tutte le altre cose che è
stato che ha detto l'italiano ci sono
questi quindi cercavo bellissimi metto
anche questo colore rosa e poi vado a
rovinare lo sai merita quindi possiamo
mettere allora solo strumenti possiamo
mettere un po di questi fili per bianchi
che vado io secondo momento non te lo
sta rovinando dello sto migliorando
questi litter pianti che secondo me è un
po di nero ci sta perché comunque un po
di glitter nero e che si possa mettere
qualcosa di pigmento grigio che ne ha 29
in mente di righe o no mi mette un po di
pigmento rosa silone ci sta bene un po
di rosa poco poco lontanto giusto per
fare un po di cozzaglia ok lo stop
migliorando e questo lo prendo io
quello che voglio e dove potrebbe
stendere quindi non s'aveva le stelline
[Musica]
pure le stelline troppo contento loro e
li hanno rimesso equiparò non ti
arrabbiare
se non ti lascia il pausa intera libera
6 di singolo testa per lei approfittato
non hai rovinato tanto il mio zio ardore
perché perché perché avuto proprio
ceduti per capire cosa ho sbagliato mi
ha messo di tutto sulla faccia da un
tipo bel mezzo dorato mezzo il grande
puffo allora mischia ma insieme alle
cose che ha aggiunto vitale questi
glitter neri che non c'entra niente ma
guardo con titolo migliorato adesso per
lo stupendo
richiedi biliardo la parete bello grazie
a me anzi che è diventato di come sia
proprio come per l'auto quelle tuttora
mag e mezzo big mettono gli scapoli
anna è sporcata gamba violetto non ha
idea di che colore uscirà marrone il
violetto però speriamo bene
vediamo un po può essere pure alberto
visto che il bird e malefico risucchia
tutto se mia mamma mi piace e vado tutte
le stelline filtrate christine e adesso
vi prego perché scompariranno nel nero
più detto che è una galassia esclusiva
scomparirà no guarda che bello che
diventa adesso che ci ho messo il
pigmento bianco da far di riflessi
stupefacenti poi ci sono le stelline che
è nota come prima sprecate tutti qui per
gli ultimi rumor idonei non so fare più
di galaxy slide prima il suo preferito
adesso non ho più fare
ma perché volevano fidato e vediamo chi
aggiunge stick e pallina non spaventare
da facciamo pensando poi che vi aggiungo
le palline bellissimo slide cosa che ti
piacciono queste qui mi spetta
le bambine amistà infondate o preferisce
le berline rossa o gialla ha una rosa
facce rosa ci stanno bene lo spot da
letto queste colorado che mi hanno
chiuso più un'accozzaglia di cose e non
ti muovere
proprio poche nonostante mettiamola così
se io sono un buono non sono come te non
ti muovere
mi è successo
oppure che non mi vendico perché il tuo
slam jam frutti di mare wine blues live
è bellissimo e super metallizzato e del
selettivo
guardate che bello azzurro il colore di
tale anche se mi avesse imposto rivolte
da cherry e vestita strofinarla perché
fitta comunque bello allora l'effetto
non è uscito proprio come te lo volevo
tipo sirenetta lo volevo fare un pochino
più trasparente
però siccome c'era il verde ma dovevo
coprire ho messo un sacco di pigmento
infatti pensato molto metallizzato
vedrete a quelli maturi metallizzate e
se iniziamo ora i soli
[Musica]
quindi falchi dei bellissimi mr
chi assiste così diamo ora quella
digitale che la mia galassia
guardate che bella nido purtroppo melo
da provinato non lo ha fatto diventare
grilletto ma io piano piano piano piano
sono riuscito poi a riprenderlo un po
diciamo che è un agate un buco che è una
bomba effettivamente bonera perché avrei
rovinato tu guarda però con stati i
colori cioè nei sette i colori
conosciuto però volevo dire guardate i
brillantini clicca le stelline non si
vedono però pazienza e niente lo
attivata un po poco perché volevo stare
attento a non attivarlo troppo sono sì
induriva e poi dopo non ci va bene tutto
il porto è stupendo
per guardare si vedono un pochettino
tutti tutti i brillantini che ho messo
poi sentiamo che fare il possibile
rumore delle bambine un pochettino se ci
sono dei montanti diciamo che
l'assessorato di foehn il suo punto di
forza sono il po king super forte quindi
chi abita a lido bricolo aree vitali per
i suoni no a vittori tale modalità le
velate che differenza di calore bel
colore problemi morbido però il colore
più belle letture non mi piace come così
freddo il tuo perché io e lo zaino
marino
allora votate quasi v3 cliccata del
fondaccio costante se vinco io servizio
e vitale e ora andate a vedere la nostra
altra pausa gialle in cui vitale mi ha
fatto uno scherzetto terribile con un
calcolato proprio tutti i pagamenti a
persone che a casa vedendo oppure
cliccare in altre delle quattro
cartellini per vedere i nostri altri
video
ciao